deathstroke arrow season 2 sorry this
seems like it's out pretty late it's not
really not comparatively I had to wait
for Netflix to have arrow season 2 it
happened last Wednesday so from
Wednesday and now it's actually pretty
good time so arrow season 2 the
continuing Adventures of Oliver Queen
he's trying to save his city and I like
how this started out because at the end
of arrow season one's a monumental [ __ ]
went down and in season 2 there are
still consequences to what happened at
the end of arrow season 1 I love that I
hate it I hate it more than a lot of
things when shows have a really intense
season finale and the season premiere
it's like alright that's wrapped up
there's no consequences anymore we're
moving on II do that have consequences
stick around for a little while this
show does that Oliver Queen feels he's
failed the city but his friends are like
hey come back so he comes back and he
picks up the arrow in the quiver in the
hood and he starts doing his thing again
of all that [ __ ] I didn't say bow that's
weird but this one he's like I gotta be
a better person I can't kill people then
I'm like oh man so you're like Batman
pretty much you're a pissed-off rich
dude with a chip on his shoulder who
won't kill people who prowls around
rooftops at night you're Batman
that's what I liked about arrow season
was the fact that he was like you were
funneled osuni BAM he'd shoot people and
kill him I guess that shows the quality
on my character that I love the fact
this vigilante is putting arrows in
people's chests and killing them the
first half of season 2 deals with the
League of Assassins and that was awesome
I mean that's Ra's al Ghul stuff and you
feel like you're gonna see more of that
and I hear you might see more there in
season 3 which is pretty sweet I have a
couple of z-list villains that people
don't really know what they are
seriously brother blood who knew that
he's no iconic character allowed shut up
he's not don't you put that keyboard
down but for the first half of the
season I was like I had more fun in
season one because it killed people it
was a simple vigilante thing but the
second half of this season Slade Wilson
he goes full Deathstroke my friends and
it is badass
this is the best rendition of
Deathstroke I thought I would ever see
in live-action form but I'm just saying
that cuz I met to do I meant to do that
Comic Con he was on the masters of web
Comicon panel that I was like he was he
was nice guy he was rad I'm glad I met
him before I saw the season cuz now I'd
be like you're scary Manu Bennett kills
it as Deathstroke man and he lives to
make Oliver Queen's life hell I just
kill him he wants to break him he wants
to make him suffer he wants to burn
everything to the ground
you're like what happened on that island
that made him so hey what'd you do to
the guy man he's so hardcore man he's a
like this rude kid I'm gonna rip your
spine out of your house home but you to
death with it and he means it he is
business my thing is I wish he did more
I mean actively did more on hands-on
[ __ ] he's like Lex Luthor behind the
scenes you know he's the man behind the
curtain he's still doing stuff and he
has his fair share of throwing down yeah
he does do stuff I just wanted to see
him do more maybe that's a perk maybe
that's a show going yeah you know you
leave the audience wanting more you
wanted more and we delivered a lot you
still wanted more yeah you're welcome
who knows it's comic book show maybe
we'll get more of Deathstroke and that
would be great the only drawback though
is that I have a brain so there are some
unbelievable things in the show some
elements from like no come on like
there's a couple of drone strike scenes
these drones are flying down like
side-by-side to a van I was like drones
are huge they're way bigger this these
things look like radio-controlled
gliders drones are actually pretty
they're bigger than that let's lay we
live in a world where they're actually
that small they would be above the
clouds and they would just be like all
right targeted targeted but not gonna go
down with the venom be like hey now is
your opportunity to take us out oh you
did convenient because we flew next to a
van that's why they don't do that [ __ ]
and black Canary's in this season I
thought that was really cool I'm all
down for an introduction to new
character but her family's in it also
and she wears this mass like a Robin
style mass just over the eyes no idea
who she is Canaries blonde her sister's
blonde she's wearing just this mask over
her eyes and she's like um yeah thank
you ma'am for saving me oh man I gotta
go meet my sister cuz you're not her
really you don't know if my brother's
saved my ass and just had a little mask
over his eyes I feel like hey man a nice
mask and this season did a good job at
building up the Robin character this one
kid's gonna be red arrow this entire
season he's being trained and you know
he's kind of falling through the cracks
and maybe Oliver Queen can help him
maybe he can't that's how you have a
sidekick come in then this season
training him so we give a [ __ ] so we're
like oh yeah man I don't know I don't
wish you any harm come on let's go fight
some crime he just came in in season
three he'd be like who are you get out
this is an exclusive club yeah I'd
already had my characters I gave you
[ __ ] acuter I'm not gonna lie the girl
who plays Felicity I think I'm in love
this might be a spoiler for the people
who are on the edge of their seat for
the romance aspect of the show I like
the fact that this show actually went
that direction because the entire time
Oliver Queen you know he's going
for this girl he's going for that girl
in the entire time I'm like you have
this absurdly attractive really
efficient nerdy in all the right ways
smart intelligent sexy female this girl
right there that you work with every day
you're not going after her
you are stupid Oliver Queen I wish you
died on that island Deathstroke get up
we'll go in full district now yeah we
are this woman he was like I love you I
should have been like oh okay Smallville
no I was like you'd sure yes correct
answer cuz any anyone with a brain would
do that she is so sexy though honestly
they have really cool comic book
easter-egg shout outs in the show they
were doing a Suicide Squad thing and
actually had the girl who played the
voice of Harley Quinn you hear her voice
and I was like oh that's awesome and
rumor is I don't know if this is factual
but rumor is because I've got them they
can't do Harley Quinn in this show so
they're not going to since Gotham is mmm
and it's on Fox when it gets canceled on
Fox and arrow can have Harley Quinn in
the show so hey Fox do what you do best
let's get Harley Quinn on the show and
Barry Allen was in this season of arrow
and the kind of springboarded him from
here and that's how he has his own show
now the flash the dude who plays Barry
Allen I thought I was like he's really
likable all right there he's a cool guy
he's a likable guys likeable nerdy dude
I want him as my flash he's my flash in
the end arrow season 2 does crank up the
volume on what season 1 gave us it nerf
Oliver Queen a bit in the sense that
he's not going to kill anyone now but
he's in the fight for his life and his
entire world I like the League of
Assassins element I love the fact that
they might bring Ra's al Ghul into the
show effect that's never bad Manu
Bennett as Slade Wilson aka Deathstroke
just he's the thing he is what you
remember from this season you walk away
go man I don't know what happened before
episode 15 because Deathstroke and [ __ ]
they brought relevance to the characters
they did what they had to do with the
characters I'm interested to see where
everyone goes that like they made Thea
his little sister more relevant I feel
like season 3 could be the thing where
they like alright everyone found their
niche let's just go and that ain't bad
so if you've checked out arrow season 1
yeah season 2 is on Netflix right now
check that [ __ ] out so arrow season 2
have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
liked what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more